Joe Becker is a Pulitzer prize-winning
investigative reporter for the New York
Times she and her colleagues published a
series of articles that broke the story
of Donald Trump Jr's meeting with the
Russian lawyer
good morning joe morning thanks for
having me president Trump has twice
applauded his son for transparency when
the New York Times first approached the
White House about this four days ago
were they transparent and forthcoming
look their story has changed multiple
times Donald Trump teen years story has
changed first he said well the meeting
was uh primarily about adoptions then
when we came back to him and said no we
haven't you know we've talked to people
who said it was also about getting dirt
on Hillary Clinton oh that he
acknowledged that maybe that was the
case then we came back to him and said
we understand that it also involved a
government effort and finally we came
back to heaven said we're going to
publish these emails the contents of
these emails and that's when he released
so I guess it's up to your viewers
decide whether that's transparent and
you said you were gonna publish the
story at 11:00 and he tweeted out the
documents when at 11:00 at 11:00 Joe can
you talk about the genesis of the
article a lot of this came with Jared
Kushner revised his revised his
statement about who he had met with
regarding his security clearance exactly
my colleagues and I in March revealed
that he had met with the Russian
ambassador the United States and also a
Russian State Bank the Russians the head
of a Russian State Bank and we followed
up and said not only had he met with
them but that he hadn't disclosed it and
as required on security clearance forms
he has in since revised his forms to
include those contacts as well as all of
his foreign contacts and it was on those
forms that he disclosed that Natalya
vessel Nets Kyah was one of the people
that he met with although he did not and
did not have to talk about what the
contents were and we just started
digging and digging do we know if there
might be more revisions then there could
be other meetings that we don't know
about right now I mean I think that they
have they they have submitted what they
think is all of the contacts I mean it's
important because of course Jared
Kushner is in a unique position here
he's at the White House he has to have
security clearance so
failure to disclose wit willfully
admitting something is a legal problem
that actually can land you in jail so
the president has called this the
greatest political witch-hunt in history
what did what are you all looking for at
the New York Times we're looking to
report the news every day and you know
nobody has said that says fake news he
said he would have Donald Trump superior
said that he would do things differently
and and I myself have done a lot of
reporting on Hillary Clinton and I I did
a story on her on the uranium one deal
that Republicans have loved to talk
about so this is not a wig when you look
joe at the cast of characters in this
story you have a russian pop star and
his dad a british entertainment
entertainment publicist a tabloid
reporter who had previous ties to trump
what stands out to you is you're going
to this story you know it what stands
out to me is that this was obviously a
very sensitive thing and it went through
the family and and friends and you know
Trump is often I mean basically you know
this is one of the things about him is
that he is said to only really you know
trust his family and so in one way it's
not surprising and another way of course
why would you put you know your family
your campaign manager in this kind of
position as somebody who I think what
trey gowdy said last night you know
she's like you know and at this points
like look if you've got crushing
contacts get it out there if you met
with dr. Zhivago if you had worked with
you know you need to get it out there
and stop dribbling it out like this
there are members of the House
Intelligence Committee who are looking
at this particular meeting and saying is
this the beginning of what were
connections between the Russian
government and that the Trump campaign
yeah I mean I think the fact that there
have been multiple stories about this
meeting sort of heightens people's
interest and makes you wonder why not
just say what this was at the outset of
our reporting I think that the line in
in the emails that is the most
intriguing of course is the line where
he says Rob Goldstone says to Donald
Trump jr. this is part of the Russian
government's effort to help to out to
help mr. Trump and
reaction isn't what are you talking
right like what effort what are you
talking to get the dirt but what are you
talking about and so it raises the
question of whether there were previous
communications communications after this
fact to around this idea of the Russian
government helping one of the things in
when Jared Kushner has revised his
disclosure forms with the federal
government in order to get this security
clearance very very serious because you
don't want to lie on these forms as you
pointed out they'll get you in jail do
we know now how many meetings Jared
Kushner has had with Russian government
officials we still don't know it's a
confidential document our initial
reporting it was things were described
to us but but we do not know the entire
list I imagine that's something that
investigators investigators at least
Mueller's people definitely have that
and have access to it I imagine Congress
is going to want that too so your
investigation continues absolutely
alright Joe Becker thank you very much